and before i came this morning i done 50
minutes of yoga
because my body aches everywhere
basically
i do a lot of gardening work and uh
you know everything hurts
so but you've got to prepare
and looking at 90 of you that was a
quite a shock that preparation for you
so look you can only look after your own
body it's no good thinking that some
america's gonna do it for you because
that's not going to happen
all right so so the best thing i can
tell you is if you're going to go to a
seminar
rather than talk on the sides
better
talk to your body on here and and just
warm it up all right anyhow it should be
easier going from now on
um
so
what i'm going to do today is i want you
to go into threes whether you change
each lesson that's up to you but staying
in threes all day
and we're gonna
we're gonna do tattoo dory and then if
we get any time left we'll do
uh joe dory
i personally find uh tattoo door and joe
dory very boring because it's difficult
and
let's just have
let's have a nick please
no
just take the jar
so
i chose nick because i knew he'd make a
nice ukemi and it'll look good but most
people would do this
he
well i couldn't go because there was
somebody standing there and
well he didn't really throw me and
so
to really to be a good uk you've got to
have a little bit of flexibility you
know so even if you don't want to take
the ukemi
because you know you're getting older or
you're stiff or you know whatever your
reason is you've got to
you've got to if you're okay likes
taking highfalls stick with that person
because they are the best
thing you can get because you'll look
good you'll feel good they feel good but
it's not really working
and cytosensei when you see him do this
and it all looks good it's because he's
got a good uk
and and i want to just tell you about um
anyway
when you're training day after day
everything starts to hurt i mean
everything even if you're in super fit
condition
joints hurt
your body's got perhaps scuffed on the
mat
it hurts so what you do is you go into
self-protection mode because you've
signed up to be an iwama you've gotta
put up with it so you go into
self-protection mode so it's easier to
take ukemi
than it is to sort of keep going i don't
want to go because what happens is by
you not going or blending
they start trying to throw you harder
so you actually get more injuries
so what i want to say today is if you
go
at least flow at least you know try and
blend with it even if you don't want to
take the the highfall you know
just just try to
the technique is to gather a little
turn it past his body we're not going to
do this i'm just showing you because
it's the west
okay
so
you can't see the power that's coming
out of me all you can see is a nice
ukemi
and i know that if nick doesn't want to
go so this time you don't want to go
he's there but at least look
everything's right now this crossover
i remember pat hendrick scentsy she said
it's the hardest of kemi to take because
you've got crossed arms you've not got
an arm that you can put down so she said
it's better to do the
ukemi
up here around the joe and that takes a
lot for nuki to be able to do that
[Applause]
but see how he
he went round the joe up here
i was watching a
youtube video of someone
and they're doing it like this
and with that joe down there
this person could break his uh
collarbone
so you so that so you'll notice when i
finished i was there and that's where he
goes around so i'm only telling you
because tattoo dory there's not a lot of
feedback you know you might sort of like
go like that you might not get a lot of
buzz back
so it's uki's job to put a lot into this
all right
so it's huge's job to put a lot into
this
okay
i'm hitting him with something different
i'm
i can't hit him with that
but you know it's like from here it's
going
oh
all right so
you put the power
of the path of non-resistance
so
when you draw him in
don't try and take too much
and then it punches
from here